[Musique]
que c'est vous la différence entre
robert badinter
l'homme qui a fait abolir la peine de
mort en france pascal lamy l'ancien
directeur général de l'om c'est
l'organisation mondiale du commerce et
le chanteur vianney qui cette année
écrit la dernière chanson des
l'année de mes 18 ans j'ai eu la chance
de m'entretenir pendant près d'une heure
avec chacune de ces personnalités
j'avais créé avec des amis un petit
concept d'émission politique et
culturelle que nous diffusions sur
internet
alors on a reçu beaucoup d'interviews
d'un burn vérité médiatique d'invités
politiques des ministres et à chaque
fois tous mes amis me faisais la même
remarque
mais julien comment est ce que tu as
fait pour les convaincre et je n'ai
jamais répondu
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous livrer
le secret de ces émissions un mercredi
après midi je vais déjeuner
tranquillement chez des amis lorsque
jean marie le pen hommes politiques
plutôt controversé était l'invité d'une
célèbre chaîne d'information alors là
j'ai regardé mes potes et je leur ai dit
ah bah tiens je les interviews dans un
mois pour mon émission sauf que c'était
totalement faux je n'avais donc plus le
choix
alors je devais trouver une solution
donc j'ai pris mon téléphone j'ai envoyé
une centaine d'image harceler son chef
de cabinet et un mois plus tard ce qui
devait arriver arriva
je me retrouvais dans son château avec
mon équipe et mes petites questions
alors nous avons fait un petit buzz sur
internet la vidéo a été vue près d'une
centaine de milliers de fois et alors
que certains ont vraiment saluer notre
travail
d'autres ont préféré nous insulter
anonymement sur les réseaux sociaux
vous imaginez mois à 18 ans je recevais
des insultes voilà et est en fait ces
insultes là eh ben je me suis rendu
compte que qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
pas les prendre en tant que tel et je me
suis dit c'est pas grave je vais essayer
de trouver une solution à ces insultes
là et en arrivant au stade des menaces
j'ai été contraint de faire appel à un
avocat pour me défendre
sauf que trouver un avocat ce n'est pas
simple
déjà je savais même pas qu'elle porte
tapez donc je suis allé sur internet et
je suis tombé sur différents sites
différentes plateformes qui prétendait
de mettre en relation avec des avocats
mais en fait c'était juste des annuaires
des listes interminables avec cinquante
mille noms d'avocats ce qui rendait la
situation bon plutôt agaçant j'étais
quand même très motivés dans ma
recherche donc j'ai décidé d'en
sélectionner une dizaine de manière un
peu aléatoire et je suis parti les
rencontrer résultat ça m'a pris beaucoup
de temps
ça m'a coûté beaucoup d'argent aussi
parce que les premiers rendez vous avec
un avocat bah c'est pas toujours gratuit
et puis surtout j'ai été très déçu de ne
pas trouver l'avocat qui me
correspondait vraiment c'est ainsi
qu'est née votre robin le service qu'ils
offrent à tous les particuliers
confrontés à un litige
une première consultation avec le baume
au coeur donc quand j'ai dit à mes amis
que je chante et je tairai augmenter une
boîte qui ambitionnait de révolutionner
la profession d'avocat la première
réaction autour de moi c'était mes
julien enfin tu n'es pas avocat je
connais même pas le secteur donc j'ai
fait croire à une centaine d'avocats en
france que je voulais monter ma boîte et
j'avais qu'un seul objectif en tête
c'était vraiment leur posais plein de
questions savoir ce qui marchait très
bien et ce qui comprenait - ce qui
marche et moins et en fait j'ai compris
que ce qui marchait plus et elle a
confiance une expérience assez drôle et
assez flippant de confiance qu'on va sur
internet
comptablement d'avocats et première
première profession qui sort son mon
avocat ne fait pas son travail mon
avocat me ment mon avocat abandonnant
dossier j'ai compris que ce qui avait
été brisée c'était la confiance etc
innover dans la profession d'avocat
s'annonce être une mission très très
compliqué dans quelques semaines je
fêterai mes 21 ans votre robin compte
désormais 500 avocats en france termine
une levée de fonds auprès de soutien
formidable et devrait continuer je
l'espère de rendre accessible la justice
pour tous dans les années à venir
je me souviens lorsque avec mon ami
lucas nous assistions aux cocktails sous
les dorures du palais de justice
organisé par la profession et c'est
super drôle parce que tous ceux qui hier
se moquer de nous nourrir et au nez sont
ceux qui aujourd'hui gêne et bt nous
serrer dans les bras et nous supplier de
devenir nos clients monter son
entreprise pas une question d'âge mais
d'énergie
ce n'est pas une question de diplômes
mais de conviction je vous présente mon
petit frère raphaël 18 ans il est avachi
sur sur le canapé porte un jogging mal
rasé et j'ai pris cette photo et je me
suis amusé elle a montré une dizaine de
personnes autour de moi
et à chaque fois chaque fois j'ai eu les
mêmes remarques c'est la décadence
c'est une génération de flemmards de
fainéants d'assister jeu mon frère qui
rigole dans la salle c'est très drôle
j'ai même réussi à entendre la fameuse
phrase c'était mieux avant sauf que non
ce n'était pas mieux avant mais juste
une autre réalité
qu'est ce que cette photo nous révèle
sur sa vie son parcours ou même sa
capacité à devenir l'homme le plus cool
de sa génération
en réalité mon petit frère est
entrepreneur depuis bien plus longtemps
que moi je me souviens lorsque j'avais
10 ans j'allais tous les dimanches bien
sagement apprendre le piano au
conservatoire lui pendant ce temps et
fabriquer des objets il vendait des
vêtements
ils étaient motivés dynamiques et prêts
à oser mais alors pourquoi est ce que la
société veut en faire le symbole d'une
jeunesse décadente alors qu'ils
représentent pour moi l'incarnation de
ce que doit être un entrepreneur
non le chef d'entreprise n'est pas qu'un
mâle blanc de plus de 40 ans gars à la
main et qui a fait de grandes études
j'ai été profondément marquées lorsqu'un
jour rafael m'a confié ne pas se sentir
intelligent c'est vrai depuis tout petit
on nous explique que chloé qui a 18 de
moyenne et plus intelligente que victor
qui n'arrive pas à dépasser les 6 en
histoire pourtant si l'on se penche sur
la définition médicale de l'intelligence
on lit que être intelligent c'est être
doté d'une forte capacité d'adaptation
ce qui n'a donc rien à voir avec les
notes
nous nous imposons beaucoup trop de
limites par peur de nous marginaliser
nous censurer nous espérer un jour
changer le monde changeait son monde
aujourd'hui j'ai intégré la plus belle
des écoles celle de l'expérience
celle qui vous responsabilise et vous
permet de franchir vos obstacle alors
qu'il ya trois ans un avocat était pour
moi une profession inconnus
aujourd'hui de gros cabinets d'affaires
juristes nous sollicitent pour les
rendre plus accessibles plus digitaux
plus mobile nous imposons beaucoup trop
de limites
lorsque je parle
entrepreneurs en devenir ou des amis
j'entends souvent les mêmes remarques
j'ai peur de me lancer je n'ai pas
d'idée c'est peut-être le cas de ses
interprètes de certaines personnes parmi
vous mais rassurez vous inutile de se
creuser la tête pendant des heures pour
inventer le dernier truc inutile dont
personne n'aura besoin
quel que soit votre âge que vous ayez 7
ans 17 ans 77 ans vous êtes énergique
vous êtes jeune alors juste regardez
autour de vous il n'existe pas de bonnes
idées mais juste des bons problèmes qui
méritent d'être résolue regardez je
trouvais impossible le fait de trouver
le bon avocat
j'ai créé votre robin un jeune homme
n'en pouvait plus de galérer dans le
froid à paris pour espérer trouver un
taxi
il a créé hubert une jeune femme ne
pouvait plus de galérer dans le froid
pour donnant pas dans le froid cette
fois de galérer pour récupérer de
l'argent lorsqu'elle réalisait dépôt
commun elle a créé litchi la création
c'est à la portée de tous lorsque
j'avais
18 ans mon père m'a mon père m'a offert
le livre qui m'a donné envie
d'entreprendre
il s'agit de zéro one de peter dille
dans son livre le cofondateur de paypal
et premier gros investisseur de facebook
et des fines et d'innovation il dit que
l'innovation c'est je cite une
contre-vérité que très peu de gens
partagent avec vous bon alors pour être
honnête j'avais pas compris la phrase du
premier coup et j'ai essayé de trouver
différents exemples pour mieux illustrer
je vous présente galilée alors que le
monde est convaincu que la terre est au
centre de l'univers
cet homme ose s'opposer à l'ordre établi
pour lui c'est le soleil qui est au
centre de l'univers et non la terre
alors bien qu'il ait dû se rétracter
pour éviter la peine de mort cet homme
avait vu le futur avant même qu'ils ne
se construisent voilà le bon exemple
d'une contrevérités que très peu de gens
partager avec vous c'est finalement
lorsque tout le monde vous dit tu vas te
planter été complètement à côté les gens
ne sont pas prêts pour ça que justement
vous devez foncé car vous êtes sur la
bonne route
je vous invite à vous demander quelle
est cette contre vérité que très peu de
gens partager avec vous soyez
resserre soyez audacieux et n'allez pas
seulement là où vous êtes attendus c'est
henry ford qui disait si j'avais demandé
aux gens ce qu'ils voulaient ils
m'auraient dit des chevaux qui courent
plus vite
n'écoutez pas toujours les autres
certains vous diront vous êtes fous et
vous allez vous planter et d'autres fous
comme moi vous dire on va zy fons tu le
seul acteur de sa propre réussite
soyez observateurs est allé coupe du
monde qui vous entoure vous êtes votre
plus grand atout que vous ressembliez à
ça à ça wassa maintenant vous n'avez
plus d' excuse plus d' excuse pour
innover dans vos vies innover dans vos
actions mais surtout pour montrer à tous
que le futur c'est vous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]